Est-ce que tu te sens juste avant de monter sur
scène devant 100 000 personnes, te
souviens-tu de la première fois que tu as rencontré
Keith Richard euh, j'ai
appris très vaguement parce que nous étions à
peu près aussi grands que cette table mais euh
oui j'ai un vague souvenir d'
un peu de sable  et un petit terrain de jeu et un
petit seau et une pelle
et cet autre gars
qu'est-ce qui te rend fou à son sujet
ah
je te dis quelle est
la question de ça très triviale mais
c'est tellement compliqué après tout tu
parles de gens qui se connaissent
depuis  plus de 40 ans,
tout ce que je peux dire, c'est que nous avons seulement tendance à nous
mettre en colère les uns contre les autres lorsque nous ne
travaillons pas ensemble, lorsque nous travaillons
ensemble, nous sommes comme ça, ouais, mais
lorsque nous ne le sommes pas,
nous avons tendance à vous trouver.  je sais toutes les
choses qui sont différentes
entre nous et alors c'est tout
mais ça ne me rend jamais vraiment en colère si c'était
vraiment très en colère, il ne serait pas un
menteur
oh
elle est surprise
parce qu'un
étranger étranger
ne peut penser à personne
vivre pour notre voyage spécial de trois ans
avec une pierre qui court laquelle
prendriez-vous Charlie déjeuner
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
attends une minute
Rocky ça dit Pokémon mort et
Yankee
si tu le veux hier
bonjour
[Musique]
ce serait brutalement honnête, alors
quelle est la question des enfants que vous avez
rencontrée le plus souvent,
euh, cette question que vous venez de lui poser,
combien de temps pensez-vous que vous allez
continuer à chanter,
pensez-vous que
vous allez continuer  pour toujours ou
pensez-vous que vous allez arrêter, donc cela
commence vers l'âge
de 20 ans et continue
maintenant, c'est le cas le plus courant
lorsque vous êtes à Berlin, l'observation est
au sud pour les cratères de bombes
dans lesquels vous jouiez  Dartford quand tu étais
enfant
non c'est une surprise
c'est encore un
étranger
[Musique]
que fais-tu avant et après le
concert pour tenir
ouais juste comme ça je bois un verre je dis
pareil j'ai quelque chose à manger je
m'assois avec  les gars on parle de ce qu'on va
faire
et euh et après on parle de
si on l'a fait ou pas mais si on l'a
bien fait
pour tenir
euh
les positions
tout le monde peut échouer
somme
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu ressens juste  avant de monter sur
scène devant 100 000 personnes je me réveille
bien je me dis d'habitude tu ferais mieux de
faire un bon show
c'est ma dernière pensée ça ferait mieux d'être
bien ils ont payé beaucoup d'argent pour
te voir arriver quand tu l'es  sur scène pour
penser à la mort de John Lennon
non, c'est autre chose à penser en
toute honnêteté euh j'y pense
peut-être euh quand je rencontre ses fils de temps en temps,
je m'en souviens mais
non sur scène je ne peux pas vraiment dire que je  m'attarder
sur la mort de quelqu'un
euhétranger,
de combien de séries avez-vous besoin pour que ça
marche
euh il y a
quelques années, j'aurais dit 10.
l'année dernière environ, je dirais une,
assez drôle, je ne sais pas pourquoi les garçons
sont  je joue juste bien, tu sais, j'ai
coulé, Dieu merci, un
membre joue sur un plaisir, je fais remarquer sur
un euh,
c'est
après combien de concerts en fais-tu comme
un travail
non si l'Allemagne est
un étranger, euh,
je ne sais pas combien de concerts j'ai fait
ça  C'est une autre blague,
tu ne peux pas te lever devant 60 60 000 ou
70 000 personnes et euh et traiter ça comme un
travail, c'est euh, il y a trop d'énergie
pour ça,
peut-être juste après le spectacle, tu es musicien
et tu parles avec les autres.  du groupe de
personnes avec lesquelles vous travaillez,
vous pourriez en parler comme d'un travail en tant que
professionnel, vous savez ce qui était
bien et ce qui n'allait pas et vous savez
le disséquer et vous le mettez sur la
table de l'opérateur et lui en donnez un peu.  du gaz
mais euh ce n'est jamais juste un travail tu sais je n'ai
jamais voulu juste un travail que
diriez-vous de négatif sur
vous-même quoi quoi quelle chose
négative
diriez-vous sur vous-même
paresseux
où changeriez-vous sur vous-même si
vous aviez la pochette magique pour ne pas être  paresseux,
aimerais-tu l'être sinon Mick Jagger
oh
ouais
Cléopâtre
Dieu
quelle différence ça fait seulement 20
millions de dollars ou 100
préparation c'est des zéros zéro signifie
rien n'as-
tu aucune sympathie pour Dieu
aurait prévu
c'est un sacré travail
que répondriez-vous à vos enfants à
des questions sur la cassonade ou le muffin de ma sœur,
écoutez-le, vérifiez, ils sont
là quand je l'écrivais, il n'y a pas de
problème, je ne l'ai pas fait, cela fait
partie de la vie ouais, ils en savent plus
que la chanson s'il te plaît
quel souvenir gardes-tu de ton premier
concert à Paris en 64.
est-ce Al Olympia
euh
étranger
L'Olympien ouais le genre d'historique
vraiment bien c'était à cause du
théâtre lui-même tu sais
euh super spectacle je me souviens que c'était presque
plein ou presque, le premier concert que
nous avons fait était en fait plein de gars au lieu
de chips parce que la plupart
du temps en Angleterre, en Europe, qui était
le seul autre endroit où nous jouions, puis c'était
uniquement des petites filles que tout d'un coup nous
avons eu à Paris et
c'était probablement la dernière chose que je faisais, c'était
la première fois que je réalisais que les
gars étaient aussi intéressés